Musique douce dramatique
...
-Vernon, Normandie.
Sur cette photo d'école prise
dans les années 50,
une tenue dénote
par rapport à celles des autres.
Un petit garçon blond porte
une culotte courte en cuir :
la tenue traditionnelle bavaroise.
Une colonie allemande a vécu ici,
au milieu des bois,
juste après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Que venaient-ils faire en France
alors que le pays se remet
difficilement des quatre années
d'occupation nazie ?
Quel mystère entourait
ces familles ?
Elles ne sont pas les seules
dans l'Hexagone.
Dans le plus grand secret,
des milliers d'Allemands
ont été transférés
sur le sol français.
-Je pensais que c'était
une organisation,
de prendre les gens
pour les déplacer
dans un autre pays,
pour travailler.
C'est en quelque sorte
une prise de guerre.
-A Vaucresson,
on a logé...
les scientifiques,
les ingénieurs,
les techniciens
qui devaient être interrogés.
-Avant d'arriver en France,
Ces hommes ont fait l'objet
d'une traque impitoyable.
Leurs poursuivants
sont des scientifiques
versés dans l'armée.
Parmi eux,
Yves Rocard,
un célèbre physicien français.
Musique énigmatique
-Mon grand-père était
un peu le dernier touche-à-tout
de la physique.
On ne pouvait pas le rouler
dans la farine.
-L'Allemagne a été passée
au peigne fin
pour retrouver des scientifiques
qui ont servi le IIIe Reich.
A quel degré ces brillants
cerveaux étaient-ils impliqués
dans le régime nazi ?
-Ils ont pris tout le monde,
même ceux qui étaient dans la SS.
-C'est une ombre de l'histoire
terrible.
Il y a une responsabilité morale,
c'est sûr.
-Ces scientifiques vont eux-mêmes
retracer leur parcours
de l'Allemagne hitlérienne
à la France de l'après-guerre.
Leurs voix se mêlent à celles
des scientifiques français
qui les ont recherchés
pour une plongée
intimiste et inédite
dans l'une des plus vastes
opérations de pillage
de la science nazie du 20e siècle.
Musique inquiétante
...
Plusieurs milliers
de scientifiques allemands
ont commencé leur carrière ici,
à Peenemunde,
tout au nord de l'Allemagne,
dans un gigantesque
centre de recherche
qui ne figure sur aucune carte.
Depuis 1942,
l'Allemagne nazie conduit là
son programme d'armes nouvelles.
-Personne ne connaissait,
à part les militaires
et les gens au pouvoir.
Autrement, c'était archi secret.
...
-Les parents d'Herbert Buhl
avaient été recrutés
par l'armée allemande
comme des milliers
d'autres ingénieurs.
Musique de tension
...
-Ma mère était dessinatrice,
très bonne dessinatrice.
Mon père était ingénieur
spécialisé
dans le guidage des fusées.
-Herbert Buhl vit aujourd'hui
en Allemagne.
Il a grandi en France.
C'est lui, le petit garçon
de la photo d'école prise
en Normandie dans les années 50.
Son histoire familiale
se mêle avec celle des débuts
de la recherche aérospatiale.
-Mon père et ma mère ont travaillé
dans l'équipe de von Braun.
Il faut dire que c'était
un grand centre de recherche
dans le domaine de la fusée,
des V1 et V2.
...
-Wernher von Braun dirige
une équipe de chercheurs
qui espèrent être les premiers
à réussir à envoyer
un objet dans l'espace.
Leurs travaux ont attiré l'attention
des haut gradés de la SS.
...
-Il y avait, par exemple,
Himmler qui était
un dirigeant
au niveau militaire,
qui avait visité Peenemunde
et qui avait vu l'intérêt
des V1 et des V2,
mais pour attaquer
d'autres pays.
Musique dramatique
...
-"Nous eûmes l'impression
en arrivant
"de nous trouver
dans un monde peint par Jules Verne.
"L'ensemble était
extrêmement impressionnant,
"la hauteur des fusées exigeant
"des ateliers de montage
adaptés en conséquence."
-Pierre Deconde est un jeune employé
français envoyé en Allemagne.
Il appartient à un bataillon
de travailleurs forcés.
-"Nous apprîmes par nos camarades
"à quoi était destinée la production
du Heimat Artillerie Park.
"Il s'agissait de mettre au point
une fusée, la V2,
"qui, d'après les rumeurs
qui circulaient,
"devait effectuer
une destruction totale
"dans un rayon de 20 kilomètres
lors de son impact."
...
-Il y a bien longtemps,
ça fait 61 ans,
que j'ai commencé
l'histoire des fusées.
En 1941,
il y avait un essai.
Nous sommes allés
à la plage
pour voir de loin
le départ de la fusée.
C'était formidable,
elle montait.
Et tout à coup,
on a entendu un son.
Là,
la fusée est revenue
et elle est tombée
dans l'eau.
Il y avait une série d'essais
qui ne marchaient pas.
Explosion
...
Enfin, le 2 octobre 1942,
c'est la première fois
qu'il y avait un essai
qui a été réussi.
Après, il y avait un dîner
au mess hôtel des officiers.
Tout le monde était heureux.
-Les Alliés apprennent l'existence
de ces nouvelles menaces.
On parle pour la V1
de bombes robots.
Ces armes meurtrières
sont pointées sur Londres.
Musique angoissante
...
Francis Rocard,
astrophysicien,
a conservé sur des bandes
enregistrées les souvenirs
de son grand-père,
Yves Rocard.
Il était le père de Michel Rocard,
l'ancien Premier ministre
et surtout un grand physicien
français.
En juin 1944, il est conseiller
scientifique du général de Gaulle
qu'il a rejoint à Londres.
*-A cette époque,
j'avais la tête farcie
des installations fort bizarres
des Allemands
sur les côtes de Normandie.
La crainte diffuse d'une arme
inconnue hantait nos esprits.
-En septembre 1944,
les premières fusées V2
s'abattent sur Londres.
Explosions
...
Musique dramatique
*-J'ouvre la porte du couloir,
plus de couloir.
Je m'approche d'une fenêtre
sur la cour, plus de cour.
Elle était remplie
de décombres du toit.
Le ciel nocturne,
irisé de faisceaux
de projecteurs,
rougeoyait avec des incendies
de tous côtés.
En franchissant la fenêtre
pour descendre sur mon toit,
j'ai eu,
pendant quelques instants,
la vision dantesque
de Londres en flammes,
sous l'effet
d'armes secrètes d'Hitler.
...
-Mon grand-père, évidemment,
était au courant de l'existence
des V1 et des V2.
Mon grand-père,
par ses compétences techniques,
a eu vent de plusieurs
avancées technologiques allemandes.
-A Londres,
on a besoin d'hommes capables
de décrypter ces nouvelles armes.
C'est la première fois
qu'un engin volant explose
à 300 kilomètres
de son point de décollage.
Musique intrigante
A Toulon, en France,
vit l'un des derniers témoins
de ces avancées spectaculaires.
...
Ursula Meindl a 101 ans.
Elle est née en Allemagne
et son destin est étroitement lié
au IIIe Reich.
...
Son père était
l'un des généraux d'Hitler.
...
-Je voulais absolument travailler
parce qu'on était déjà en guerre
et je ne voulais pas faire un métier
sans aider
à notre victoire.
-Ursula est alors
une toute jeune femme
qui a fait partie
des Jeunesses hitlériennes.
Elle a 20 ans
quand la guerre éclate.
-Je me suis complètement
fait prendre
par cette éternelle réclame
que tout le monde,
les journaux et tout
ont fait autour d'Hitler :
Hitler, il fait ceci,
il fait cela...
"Oh, quel magnifique homme !"
Et moi, je l'ai cru.
Moi, j'étais une fanatique
pour Hitler.
Si j'avais su
tout ce qui se passait en notre nom
et qu'il y avait
toutes ces atrocités
autour de nous,
j'aurais été probablement
franchement contre.
Mais en ne sachant rien de tout ça,
c'est devenu une normalité.
Musique grave
-Les industries civiles
sont converties
pour fabriquer des armes.
Toute la population allemande
est réquisitionnée.
Ursula passe la guerre
à travailler
dans les usines.
Elle devient l'assistante
d'un ingénieur
en charge de la conception
de l'aile d'une torpille
larguée d'un avion.
-C'était une aile
qu'on aurait pu mettre
sur n'importe quoi,
mais elle était prédestinée
à être mise sur une torpille.
A l'époque,
ça n'existait pas.
C'est probablement
un dernier espoir
de gagner cette guerre.
-C'était assez redoutable.
Le principe, c'est que le pilote
avait une bombe avec des ailes,
la bombe est larguée
et le pilote avait
un manche pour piloter l'avion
et un autre pour la bombe.
Donc il faisait en sorte
que la bombe
pointe vers le bateau,
et le bateau explosait.
-Les Alliés demandent à Yves Rocard
de trouver une parade.
*-J'ai fait des petits brouilleurs
que j'ai fait installer
sur tous nos croiseurs.
Un a servi au moment
du débarquement dans le Midi.
Les bombes ont été s'écraser
à 500 m derrière.
Autrement dit,
j'ai eu des petits succès
techniques.
-Les armées de l'air
anglaise et américaine
reprennent peu à peu le contrôle
de l'espace aérien.
Grondement des bombes
Musique de tension
...
Propos en allemand
-"Maintenant,
la guerre se rapproche
"de plus en plus
de notre sol bien-aimé.
"Donaueschingen a souffert
de la première attaque aérienne.
"La rue le long de la Brigach,
"avec les belles maisons
à colombages, est détruite.
"Il y a beaucoup de morts.
C'est horrible.
"Tous les villages
entre Donaueschingen
"et le lac de Constance
ont subi des raids aériens.
"Nous allons nous y habituer,
"comme toutes les autres régions
avant nous."
...
Musique solennelle
-"Nous nous trouvons
dans une situation très difficile.
"J'espère que nous pourrons
nous en sortir une fois de plus.
"Jusqu'ici, nous réussissons,
"au prix d'infinis soucis
et peu de sommeil."
-Je recevais quand même
assez de lettres de sa part
pour voir qu'il était
très pessimiste.
...
Mon père n'y croyait plus du tout,
mais il a fait son devoir de soldat
jusqu'à la fin,
parce que c'était ça.
C'était pas parce qu'il était nazi,
c'était parce qu'il était soldat.
-Les armes miracle n'ont pas permis
de changer le cours de la guerre.
Le territoire des vaincus
est réduit
à un champ de ruines,
mais pour les Alliés,
c'est aussi une mine d'or
de technologies d'avant-garde
qui suscitent déjà
la convoitise des vainqueurs.
...
Musique pesante
-"Par un beau matin de 1945,
j'étais assis
"dans la cabine d'un camion
de l'aviation américaine
"en train de rebondir
sur les routes
"semées de trous de bombes
dans le centre de l'Allemagne.
"J'étais en mission,
mais c'était une curieuse mission :
"j'avais dans la poche
"des ordres secrets m'assignant
à l'exécution du projet Lusty,
"une opération extra-rapide
"menée par l'aviation américaine
pour débusquer et mettre la main
"sur tous les savants nazis
d'Allemagne.
"L'opération Lusty n'était
qu'une partie du plan général
"nommé opération Paperclip."
-Paperclip est le nom
du plan secret américain.
Les Anglais et les Soviétiques
ont prévu d'en faire autant.
...
Mais les savants d'Hitler
ont reçu l'ordre
de dissimuler leurs travaux.
Les forêts, les tunnels,
les grottes
leur ont servi de cachette.
Pour échapper aux Alliés,
des milliers d'entre eux
se sont fondus
dans le flot des réfugiés.
Parmi eux,
Wernher von Braun,
le concepteur des fusées nazies.
Il s'est volatilisé
avec tous ses spécialistes.
...
-C'était la décision...
du service militaire à Berlin
qu'il fallait évacuer Peenemunde,
aussi bien les scientifiques
que tout le savoir,
les papiers, les documents,
et de se retirer
dans la forteresse bavaroise,
parce que ça,
c'était l'idée d'Hitler,
qu'on allait trouver un refuge
dans les Alpes.
C'était complètement idiot,
mais c'était leur idée.
-Il n'y a plus de sanctuaire.
Le réduit bavarois
dont Hitler avait fait sa retraite
tombe à son tour.
En mai 1945,
toute l'Allemagne,
prise en tenaille
entre les armées américaine,
anglaise, française,
et soviétique de l'autre,
est occupée.
Les concepteurs des fusées
se rendent.
Leur chef, Wernher von Braun,
est soulagé
le jour de son arrestation :
il est sorti vivant du chaos.
...
-Mon père, d'abord,
se trouvait en sécurité
avec toute l'équipe,
avec von Braun.
Pour eux, c'était vraiment
primordial et crucial
de tomber sous la main
des Américains,
parce que là, on était sûr
qu'ils étaient bien traités
et que, de toute façon,
ils étaient reconnus
pour leur science
et pour leur savoir.
-Dans les capitales européennes,
alors que les populations
se réjouissent
de la chute du IIIe Reich,
l'inquiétude monte
parmi leurs gouvernants.
A Paris, le Gouvernement provisoire
a appris que les Américains
avaient retrouvé
des spécialistes des fusées.
Le temps presse pour profiter
de cette manne exceptionnelle.
Il faut reconstruire le pays,
ruiné par cinq années d'occupation.
*-Moi-même,
je revenais de la guerre.
J'étais habillé en marin,
ingénieur en chef
de la marine.
J'avais eu des négociations
avec le chef du deuxième bureau
de la marine.
Il m'a appuyé sur l'idée
qu'il fallait faire
un effort considérable
pour mettre la main
sur les techniques
et techniciens allemands
après la guerre,
parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de choses
pour lesquelles nous recevions
des coups sans comprendre.
J'avais le sentiment
que nous avions beaucoup
à apprendre.
-Il y a un obstacle majeur :
la France, à genoux
après cinq années d'occupation,
a collaboré avec l'ennemi.
Elle est donc
tenue à l'écart
du butin des vainqueurs.
Le général de Gaulle,
qui dirige
le Gouvernement provisoire,
va s'interposer,
au nom de l'intérêt supérieur
de la France.
De Gaulle pense que le pays
ne peut se passer
de l'apport allemand.
Secrètement,
il donne l'ordre à son armée
de faire main basse
sur les savants d'Hitler.
...
-"Il y aura lieu de transférer
en France les scientifiques
"ou techniciens allemands
de grande valeur
"pour les faire interroger à loisir
sur leurs travaux
"et éventuellement les engager
à rester à notre disposition."
*-La marine a monté
une petite section,
la section T marine,
comportant une centaine d'hommes
sous les ordres
d'un lieutenant de vaisseau
avec un armement léger
pour accompagner
les armées françaises
au fur et à mesure
qu'elles envahissaient l'Allemagne.
C'était moi qui inspirais
leurs missions et leur travail.
-Il a été envoyé en Allemagne
alors que la France
n'y avait pas droit,
c'était les gagnants,
les Américains et les Anglais,
mais discrètement,
les Français le faisaient.
-Des unités de recherche
vont donc se mêler aux troupes
du général de Lattre de Tassigny.
Terre, mer, air,
chaque corps d'armée possède
sa propre section scientifique.
Par pragmatisme,
le haut commandement français
s'apprête à désobéir
aux consignes des Alliés,
et la chance va lui sourire.
...
-"De nombreux laboratoires
importants
"ont été évacués
dans le Wurtemberg.
"On attendait impatiemment
que cette zone soit occupée
"quand de nouvelles complications
ont surgi.
"Ce territoire
scientifiquement désirable
"allait être pris
par les troupes françaises."
...
-Le général de Gaulle a joué
là encore un rôle déterminant.
A force d'insister
auprès de Winston Churchill,
il arrache en juillet 1945
la promesse que la France
aura elle aussi le droit
d'occuper une partie
de l'Allemagne.
Le pays a finalement été divisé
en quatre zones,
attribuées à chacune des armées
qui l'ont envahi.
Le petit territoire
attribué à la France est prometteur.
Il comprend le lac de Constance,
au bord duquel
des centaines d'ingénieurs allemands
ont trouvé refuge.
Tous ont poursuivi leur travail
jusqu'au bout.
Parmi eux,
il y a Ursula Meindl,
toujours occupée à des calculs
pour améliorer l'aile
de la torpille planante.
-C'était des officiers
qui venaient
en tant que force occupante.
Ca nous gênait pas du tout.
Ils étaient très corrects.
Ils nous regardaient faire.
Ils étaient très intéressés
par notre aile.
Musique douce
C'était nos patrons,
en quelque sorte.
...
*-Ma position personnelle
était de parler très poliment
aux Allemands et de dire :
"Ce que vous avez fait
est très intéressant.
"Continuez.
On vous met simplement
"deux marins en faction
devant la porte
"pour que vous puissiez continuer
de travailler tranquilles."
...
-Yves Rocard
note toutes ses recherches
dans des carnets.
A de nombreuses reprises,
il se déplace en Allemagne
pour interroger les scientifiques.
Leur nom, leur fonction,
leurs travaux,
tout est recensé ici
de manière méticuleuse.
Yves Rocard reconstitue
intégralement
les organismes des instituts
technologiques allemands.
-Le spectre est assez large,
donc on peut citer
ces affaires de torpille
électromagnétique
sur laquelle il s'est intéressé,
on peut citer les bombes volantes,
mais aussi tout ce qui était
cellules au sulfure de plomb,
cellules infrarouges.
Il y avait une avancée
dans ce domaine en Allemagne,
et ça a été récupéré
à ce moment-là.
Musique intrigante
...
-L'Allemagne se révèle être
un eldorado
pour tous les scientifiques
dépêchés sur place.
...
On découvre ici
le nouveau carburant
à propergol liquide
des fusées nazies.
...
Là, ce sont les éléments
d'une installation
révolutionnaire pour l'époque
qu'on achemine en France.
...
C'est une soufflerie,
un équipement
destiné à tester
l'aérodynamisme
des avions et des fusées.
Elle est remontée pièce par pièce
à Modane, en Savoie.
...
Le site est toujours utilisé.
C'est encore
la plus grande soufflerie du monde.
...
Pour exploiter
ces avancées technologiques,
il faut pouvoir mettre la main
sur leurs brillants inventeurs.
...
Parmi les hommes les plus convoités,
il y a les patrons
du complexe militaro-industriel.
...
Ferdinand Porsche
est activement recherché.
Chef de l'entreprise de moteurs
Porsche,
il a mis son empire
au service d'Hitler.
Il a fabriqué ses avions,
ses chars
et du matériel de guerre
en quantité industrielle.
Musique de tension
Mais il demeure introuvable,
comme Willy Messerschmitt.
Le grand fournisseur d'avions
de la Luftwaffe,
l'armée de l'air allemande,
est l'inventeur
du premier avion à réaction
du monde.
...
*-J'ai monté
une sorte de commando.
J'ai capturé Messerschmitt,
qui était sur le point
d'être évacué
par une unité SS
vers la Suisse,
et j'ai pu le ramener
vers les lignes alliées.
...
J'avais déjà récupéré
toutes les archives de Messerschmitt
au fond d'un lac
où elles avaient été immergées,
dans le Tyrol.
Le dernier camion français partait
lorsqu'est arrivé
tout un bataillon américain
avec des forces puissantes.
Ils sont arrivés
un peu après la bataille.
D'ailleurs,
ils m'en ont voulu.
...
-Les Américains
ont repris Messerschmitt,
mais les Français ont eu le temps
de l'interroger
et de copier ses travaux.
Les Alliés se livrent
une concurrence féroce.
Des scientifiques disparaissent
mystérieusement.
...
Musique douce
*-J'avais mis la main
sur d'excellents ingénieurs
et agents techniques
de laboratoire de torpilles.
Ces Allemands furent regroupés
dans une ferme
des environs de Kressbronn.
Nos premiers ennuis vinrent
de nos concurrents américains,
qui avaient mis le cap
sur le même groupe que nous.
Le conseiller de l'armée américaine,
le célèbre von Karman,
me dit : "Vous, les Français,
vous êtes bien naïfs de croire
"que ces Allemands
sont tous des génies."
Il ne m'encourageait pas à traiter
avec les techniciens allemands,
mais il déclencha l'action
des services secrets américains
dans le but de faire évader
les Allemands.
Ceux-ci quittaient
la zone française,
enlevés à notre barbe,
dans une voiture américaine.
...
-Il y a eu de nombreuses équipes
qui ont fait ça.
Les Américains
l'ont fait énormément,
les Anglais aussi.
C'était un peu des peaux de banane
et compagnie.
On se faisait pas de cadeaux.
...
-Pour les convaincre
de rester au service de la France,
les scientifiques allemands
sont choyés.
Un petit groupe
de spécialistes de fusées
est installé dans cette auberge,
à Emmendingen.
Pendant qu'ils dessinent
les plans des V2,
les autorités françaises
prennent en charge
tous les aspects matériels.
...
Propos en allemand
-Nous étions
une trentaine d'ingénieurs.
Nous avons négocié
avec le ministère des Armées.
L'affaire a bien évolué.
Nous avons obtenu
des documents français
qui protégeaient nos familles.
Nous avions
un supplément de nourriture,
ce qui, à l'époque,
était important,
vu la misère
qui régnait en Allemagne.
-Wilhelm Dollhopf
vérifiait les calculs
des moteurs de fusées V2.
Il était soulagé
d'avoir retrouvé du travail.
-Ce qu'on sait très rarement,
c'est que, en Allemagne,
les restrictions ont commencé
le premier jour de la guerre,
en 39,
si bien qu'à la fin de la guerre,
nous avions vraiment faim.
On était vraiment sous-alimentés.
Musique grave
-Des dizaines
de laboratoires allemands
travaillent ainsi
pendant plus d'un an
pour l'armée et la recherche
françaises.
...
-"Nous sommes en mars 46,
en plein travail
"sur notre empennage
pour torpille planante,
"quand surgit l'ingénieur
du génie maritime.
"Il déclare que notre travail
doit cesser en Allemagne.
"La consternation est grande."
...
-Les recherches à but militaire
sont interdites sur le sol allemand,
pour éviter que l'Allemagne
ne se réarme et ne redevienne
une puissance hostile.
...
*-Au bout de quelques mois,
il y a eu les instructions
de déménager en France
les institutions
que nous avions fondées.
-Si on veut continuer
à exploiter ce potentiel,
ces ingénieurs,
ces gens qu'ils connaissent,
il faut les faire venir en France,
donc il n'y a pas trop
d'alternatives.
-Evidemment, pour nous,
c'était très étonnant,
parce qu'on pensait
qu'après la guerre,
des déplacements forcés comme ça,
ce n'était plus possible.
-C'est là où on fait
des propositions alléchantes,
un peu carotte et le bâton.
Je me souviens
que mon grand-père me disait
qu'il arrivait
avec des propositions,
de faire venir la famille,
de salaire, etc.,
mais aussi, s'ils refusaient,
ils les emmenaient de force.
...
-Pour les savants d'Hitler,
c'est l'exode.
...
Les Etats-Unis ont déjà transféré
sur leur territoire
118 spécialistes des fusées,
avec leur ingénieur en chef,
Wernher von Braun,
qui deviendra l'architecte
du programme spatial américain.
...
Les Soviétiques vont organiser
le déménagement forcé
de milliers
de chercheurs en URSS.
...
Des voix s'élèvent
pour protester contre l'arrivée
d'anciens nazis.
Mais qui étaient-ils vraiment,
ces collaborateurs zélés
du IIIe Reich ?
...
Musique intrigante
-J'ai encore les laissez-passer
pour entrer en France
pour aller à Paris.
Et à Paris, on était reçus
à la Gare de l'Est,
dans un bureau.
Ils étaient là, avec deux voitures,
je crois.
Et on nous amenait à Vaucresson,
dans le château de Vaucresson.
...
-C'est là qu'un, je crois,
monsieur Levy...
dont je n'ai plus jamais entendu
parler par la suite,
nous a interrogés.
Il nous a posé des questions
sur nos activités pendant la guerre,
sur ce que nous savions.
Musique pesante
-Mon père a été questionné.
...
On lui a remis
un questionnaire à remplir.
Et là, il a écrit dedans
qu'il avait été SA.
Donc la France,
et aussi les Américains,
ils savaient qu'il était SA,
ils sont quand même intéressés.
...
Bruits de botte
-La SA est la première
milice privée,
qui dans les années
30, a oeuvré pour ouvrir
la voie du pouvoir
aux fascistes en Allemagne.
...
-Si on voulait
faire quelque chose,
il fallait être
dans la SA.
Ca prouvait
qu'on était engagé pour...
Pour le régime, quoi.
A mon avis, il faut différencier
entre un engagement fort
et un engagement
un peu banal.
Musique mélancolique
Il est rentré dans la SA,
pas la SS, la SA.
Et il en est ressorti
quelques années plus tard.
Pour moi...
Je pense que mon père
n'était pas tellement
engagé là-dedans.
Musique pesante
...
-On devait,
sous Hitler,
jurer fidélité et tout ça
au Fuhrer.
Et après, c'était pratiquement
pas possible
de s'en aller sans difficulté.
...
-Karl Benhke travaillait lui aussi
sur les V2.
Il a subi le même
interrogatoire de la part
des services secrets
français.
...
-Mon père, à Peenemunde,
était scientifique,
mais je ne pense pas
qu'il ait vraiment adhéré
aux idées d'Hitler.
On peut pas dire qu'on en ait
discuté vraiment ensemble,
mais c'est le sentiment que j'ai.
C'était quelqu'un de bon.
Je pense qu'il faisait son travail,
voilà.
...
-Karl Benhke a adhéré à la SA
à partir de 1934,
et plus tard, au parti nazi.
Christelle, sa fille,
n'était pas au courant.
...
La tentation
de tirer un trait
sur la guerre, de cacher
son engagement politique
a été très répandue
dans l'Allemagne de l'après-guerre.
C'est ce que découvre Ursula Meindl
le jour où à son tour,
on vient l'interroger.
-La sécurité navale
est venue chez moi
juste avant mon départ.
C'était un officier de la sécurité
qui avait comme tâche
de voir les Allemands
dangereux ou pas.
Il m'a demandé :
"Vous étiez pas nazi ?"
J'ai dit : "Monsieur,
c'est assez difficile
"de trouver quelqu'un en Allemagne
qui n'était pas nazi."
En quelque sorte, oui,
j'étais nazi.
Et puis finalement,
il était un peu pris de court.
Il s'est levé,
il s'est incliné devant moi,
et m'a dit : "Mademoiselle,
vous êtes le premier nazi
"que je rencontre en Allemagne.
"De mon côté, vous avez rien
à craindre."
Ca, c'était...
Et ça, ça m'a mise
dans une colère noire
contre les Allemands.
Je me dis : "Mais comment
il se comporte ?
Qu'un officier me dise ça,
qu'il me dise :
"Mademoiselle,
vous êtes le premier nazi
"que je rencontre
en Allemagne."
Ca, c'est inadmissible, pour moi,
parce que ça montrait
qu'on s'est mis derrière
un parapluie,
qu'on n'y était pour rien,
alors qu'on était ce qu'on était.
On pouvait très bien
avouer ce qu'on était.
...
-Aucun profil n'arrête
les recruteurs,
même les plus compromis.
Otto Ambros,
chimiste,
ami personnel d'Himmler,
a donné son feu vert
à l'usage du Zyklon B,
à Auschwitz.
...
C'est le gaz utilisé
pour l'extermination
des juifs d'Europe.
Otto Ambros
est sur la liste
des criminels de guerre.
Pourtant,
à la Libération,
il est embauché
par une entreprise française
de colorants chimiques.
La France finit par le livrer
aux Américains.
Ce tribunal dressé pour juger
les crimes commis
à Auschwitz le condamne
à huit ans de prison en 1947.
...
Combien d'autres ont échappé
à tout jugement ?
...
Pendant la Seconde guerre mondiale,
au centre de l'Allemagne,
près de Nordhausen, une gigantesque
usine sous-terraine a été creusée
sur ordre des nazis en 1943.
Il fallait poursuivre
la fabrication
des V2 dans un lieu sûr,
à l'abri des bombardements alliés.
Quand les troupes américaines
découvrent le site
en avril 1945,
elle découvre l'enfer.
La construction
du camp de Dora
a été une hécatombe.
Les soldats américains évacuent
les corps suppliciés des déportés
forcés à travailler
jusqu'au dernier jour
dans les entrailles militaires
du régime.
...
-Nous sommes restés
72 heures debout,
sans nourriture
et sans sommeil.
Des grappes humaines de corps nus
s'agglutinaient les unes aux autres
afin de rechercher
un semblant de chaleur.
...
Comment résister à une température
de -25 degrés ?
Vision dantesque, ahurissante.
Il mourrait bien davantage d'hommes
qu'il ne sortait de fusées.
...
-Ces dessins
ont été réalisés sur place
par un prisonnier français.
Ils témoignent
de la brutalité des kapos.
...
Les ingénieurs étaient présents,
comme le prouvent ces clichés
pris par un photographe officiel
du régime.
Comment se sont-ils comportés
envers cette main d'oeuvre
réduite en esclavage ?
...
-Au début du mois de mars 1944,
on nous a annoncé la visite
d'un groupe d'ingénieurs.
L'un d'eux m'a aperçu
et a foncé vers moi, m'a giflé,
invectivé, m'a accusé de sabotage
parce que j'avais posé le pied
sur un petit moteur de guidage
de l'aileron de la fusée.
Après son départ,
mon chef d'équipe m'a dit
qu'il s'agissait
de Wernher von Braun.
-Il paraît
qu'il y avait du sabotage
dans ces galeries sous-terraines,
que les Allemands essayaient
de détecter à temps.
Certainement que ça a eu lieu.
Et celui qui était pris, évidemment,
c'est très malheureux,
c'était la peine de mort.
Tout ça, c'est sûr que c'est
une ombre de l'histoire terrible.
-Des dizaines d'autres sites
souterrains ont été construits
pour la fabrication
des armes du régime nazi,
laissant dans leur sillage
des milliers de morts.
-Alors, il est fragile.
Elle soupire.
"Contrat de prestation de services
entre le ministère de l'Armement
"mademoiselle Meindle Ursula."
-Ursula Meindle décroche
à son tour en 1947
un contrat
d'assistante technique
dans un laboratoire
de la marine française.
-C'était tellement incroyable
que ça se soit passé comme ça
et que personne n'a vu ce filtre
qu'ils auraient pu mettre
en disant :
"Elle est la fille d'un général
qui s'est battu en Normandie
"contre nous, qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on en fasse ?"
Non, non, ça passait.
-Leur degré d'adhésion
au régime nazi a été très variable.
Seule certitude :
la France a accueilli
plusieurs milliers d'anciens
collaborateurs du IIIe Reich.
On estime leur nombre
à 5000 environ.
...
Musique légère
-Vernon s'offre à la flânerie.
Des roches, quelques grottes,
allons voir !
Un carrefour,
une plaque "LRBA".
Il faut montrer patte blanche
pour entrer au laboratoire
de recherche balistique
et aérodynamique de Vernon.
...
-C'était caché sur le plateau,
complètement à l'extérieur
de Vernon.
Et pratiquement,
les autres Français de Vernon
n'avaient ni accès
ni grosse connaissance de ces lieux.
Musique pesante
-En mai 1946,
un premier groupe s'installe.
70 ingénieurs
qui ont mis au point les V2
sont chargés de doter la France
d'une fusée.
...
Peu à peu,
on construit pour eux
une soufflerie,
des stands d'essai
pour les moteurs :
une cité de l'espace voit le jour.
...
-Au mois de septembre 47,
je suis arrivé à Vernon.
J'étais dans la section vannes,
soupapes...
J'avais une chambre
au baraquement E,
à l'entrée,
qui est détruit maintenant.
On était bien traités,
contents de travailler en France.
Musique mélancolique
...
-Sur ces images rares,
tournées par l'un
de ces scientifiques,
on aperçoit les maisons
mises à leur disposition.
Les femmes et les enfants
rejoignent les pères de famille
dans les mois qui suivent.
Le déménagement
est pris en charge,
les salaires sont bons.
La France leur a déroulé
le tapis rouge.
...
-Pour vivre,
pour jouer, tout ça,
on était très bien
au LRBA.
D'ailleurs, on disait
"lieu de repos bien aménagé".
Rires d'enfants
C'est vrai que pour les enfants,
c'était le paradis,
de jouer, je faisais
des gros bouquets de muguet,
je cherchais des mûres
avec ma mère,
de fraises des bois.
On mettait ça dans du vin blanc
et c'était de la "baule",
c'était une boisson
qu'on buvait en Allemagne,
un genre de sangria.
...
-Les premières années,
la colonie allemande
reproduit son mode de vie
à l'identique.
Les fêtes traditionnelles,
comme le carnaval des enfants,
ponctuent l'année.
A première vue, l'arrivée
des spécialistes en Normandie
ne pose aucune difficulté.
...
-Je crois que la peur
d'aller à l'étranger
a été tout de suite oubliée,
voyant comment on les traitait
en France.
Ils étaient traités aussi bien
au point de vue paiement.
Comme un Français,
ils étaient très bien payés.
Musique pesante
-Un second groupe rejoint le premier
pour construire
des moteurs de chars.
La colonie allemande
compte désormais
130 scientifiques.
De nouvelles maisons
sont mises en chantier.
Alors que la ville de Vernon,
bombardée par l'aviation allemande
en 1940,
n'est toujours pas
reconstruite.
-La ville était quand même
beaucoup détruite, dévastée.
Et les Vernonais,
de voir ces camions
qui montaient avec des aglos,
du ciment, du sable,
tout ce qu'il fallait
pour construire,
ils le prenaient pas très bien,
ce qui est tout à fait logique.
Et franchement,
après toute cette violence
qui a été connue de par la faute
des Allemands,
moi, je comprends.
...
-Cette installation aux portes
d'une cité meurtrie
déclenche l'hostilité
des habitants.
...
Les enfants allemands,
scolarisés avec les Français,
le ressentent.
-On était reconnus de loin,
avec cette culotte en cuir.
Il y avait une haine.
Les Français
traitaient les Allemands
de Boches.
Les écoliers,
les camarades scolaires,
reprenaient ça.
On s'est quand même interrogé
sur tout ce qu'on a...
Toute l'histoire, finalement,
des Allemands à Vernon.
De toute façon,
on était très jeunes.
Mais on se disait :
"Pourquoi on est mal vus ?
"Pourquoi il y a des tensions ?"
-Notre frère aîné, lui, il avait
à peu près, je dirais 18 ans,
et lui, il est allé travailler
comme apprentis
chez un électricien
en ville.
Il allait faire des installations
chez dans particuliers.
...
-Karl Benhke a placé son fils
en apprentissage
chez un électricien français.
...
-Et lui, il a subi
quelques agressions.
C'était plus difficile.
-Battu sauvagement, le jeune homme
en gardera des séquelles.
Sa famille n'a jamais porté plainte.
-Ca a été assumé.
On a fait du mieux qu'on a pu,
mais voilà.
Hm-hm.
Oui, oui.
Mais enfin, il faut avouer
que c'est une période
qui n'était pas facile.
Passage de train
-L'arrivée des Allemands
suscite partout
la peur
et l'incompréhension.
A Decize, dans la Nièvre,
170 ingénieurs débarquent,
en juillet 1946.
...
Avec leurs 272 wagons remplis
d'outillage, ils ne pouvaient pas
passer inaperçu.
Musique pesante
...
-Aujourd'hui, nos rues
sont à nouveau pleines
de silhouettes
que nous reconnaissons
pour les avoir trop connues.
L'uniforme n'y est plus,
mais nous reconnaissons l'allure
et le regard.
Les habitants de Decize
se rappellent surtout
les derniers Teutons,
ivres de fureur,
et armés jusqu'aux dents
partir en expédition
contre les maquis du Morvan.
Personne n'oublie.
Musique haletante
-les craintes de la population
n'ont pas pesé lourd
face à la raison d'Etat.
L'ingénieur en chef du groupe,
Hermann Oestrich,
a mis au point l'un
des tout premiers moteurs
à réaction.
Ces bombardiers Me 262
représentaient
une avancée technologique
majeure.
Pour venir travailler
en France,
le ministère de l'Armement
lui a fait un pont d'or.
Oestrich a dicté ses conditions
pour mettre au point
le premier moteur
à réaction français.
5 % du prix lui revient
sur chaque exemplaire fabriqué.
...
Le gouvernement français entourait
d'une discrétion maximale
l'installation
de dizaines de laboratoires
civils et militaires.
Les moteurs à réaction à Decize,
les sous-marins à Cherbourg,
les avions de chasse à Melun...
Dans tous ces centres, des Allemands
travaillent pour la France,
car la priorité est donnée
au retour du pays parmi
les puissances mondiales.
...
Musique mélancolique
-A mon arrivée ici, en février,
les arbres et les buissons
ployaient sous leur charge
luxuriante.
A Fréjus, je fais la connaissance
de mes nouveaux camarades.
Ce sont des ingénieurs
amenés ici d'office,
mais ils disent
qu'ils s'y plaisent.
Le personnel allemand se compose
d'une trentaine d'ingénieurs
et d'une dizaine de techniciens.
Je suis appelée chez
le professeur Bitl, physicien.
Il m'apprendra
en acoustique sous-marine
tout ce qui me sera utile plus tard.
Pendant quatre ans,
nous travaillerons ensemble.
-Au début, nous étions
des ingénieurs
et techniciens allemands,
avec deux techniciens français.
Tout ce qui était scientifique
ou savoir,
c'était dirigé par les Allemands.
-Ursula Meindle fait partie
des effectifs embauchés
par la marine.
Elle travaille dans l'un
des trois centres expérimentaux
de la Côte d'Azur,
ouverts grâce au recrutement
d'Yves Rocard.
-J'avais embauché tous
ces ingénieurs et techniciens,
qui étaient très bons
et qu'on a transférés
en France au laboratoire du Brusc.
Ils avaient la solution
pour ces torpilles
qui se retournent
sous les bateaux et explosent.
-Entre Français et Allemands,
ça marchait très, très bien.
Plus le travail
que je faisais était important,
plus j'étais contente de pouvoir
montrer que c'était possible.
C'est presque incroyable...
J'ai été
une des rares personnes
qui était au courant
qu'il allait y avoir
des sous-marins nucléaires.
C'était classifié.
La marine française avait
une sacrée confiance en moi.
Musique douce
-Ursula Meindl passe
son diplôme d'ingénieur
et sert fidèlement
les intérêts de la France.
Les autorités militaires
lui imposent
un silence complet
sur la nature de son travail.
Dans son contrat, il est écrit
qu'en cas d'espionnage,
c'est la peine de mort.
-J'ai trouvé ça un peu dur,
que ce soit dans un contrat.
S'ils veulent qu'on le sache,
c'est leur truc, quoi.
D'ailleurs, ça risquait pas beaucoup
qu'il fallait me le dire
parce que je suis née
dans une famille militaire
où on savait
de quoi on pouvait parler
et de quoi
on ne pouvait pas parler.
Ca, je le savais déjà petite.
-Ursula Meindl
a été une pionnière.
Elle a créé le premier service
de mesure des bruits sous-marins,
une discipline nouvelle
qui a permis d'augmenter la sécurité
à bord des submersibles.
-Les sous-mariniers,
c'était les premiers
qui ont compris
que j'avais raison
et qui m'ont adoptée
à partir de ce moment-là.
Maintenant,
il y a des oreilles d'or.
C'est vraiment devenu quelque chose
qui a été compris.
-La greffe a pris.
Les premiers instituts de recherche
franco-allemands voient le jour.
Leurs travaux vont permettre
à la France de rattraper son retard.
-Finalement,
avec le temps,
les Français et les Allemands
vont se réconcilier.
C'est effectivement
ce qui s'est passé.
Musique intrigante
...
-A la fin des années 50,
le fruit de ces collaborations
se concrétise.
...
*-Le 22e Salon de l'aéronautique,
qui vous est présenté, révèle
au monde étonné le prodigieux essor
de notre aéronautique nationale.
Depuis la guerre, nos constructeurs,
nos centres d'essais,
nos services techniques ont fait
d'une industrie mise en sommeil,
une des plus florissantes
et sûrement la plus vivante
qui soit.
-Le Salon du Bourget 1957
est une vitrine mondiale
pour les réalisations
technologiques françaises.
Le pays vient de se doter
de ses premiers avions à réaction.
*-Mystère IV,
Marcel Dassault, France,
intercepteurs
et avions d'appui transsoniques
qui équipent
les forces aériennes de l'OTAN.
-Personne ne précise
que le concepteur
du premier moteur à réaction
est allemand.
Hermann Oestrich
l'a mis au point à Decize.
Musique inquiétante
-Les prouesses technologiques
épatent
les visiteurs,
mais leur ADN reste inconnu.
Le Djinn est un hélicoptère léger
qui bat des records d'altitude.
...
Le nom des deux ingénieurs allemands
qui l'ont conçu
n'est jamais prononcé.
Le clou du Salon de l'espace,
c'est cet appareil futuriste.
*-Atar volant C400 P2, France,
appareil expérimental
pour l'étude du décollage
et de l'atterrissage à la verticale
construit par la SNECMA.
On songe à équiper le réacteur
d'une aile annulaire,
dont la partie intérieure
sera pourvue d'un statoréacteur.
-Le comte Helmut von Zborowski
en est l'inventeur.
Il faisait partie
des unités d'élite de la SS.
Mais c'est aussi un génie,
enlevé à la fin de la guerre
aux Américains.
Arrivé en France,
il a mis au point
le premier avion à décollage
vertical au monde.
S'il ne s'était pas crashé
lors d'un essai,
ce curieux engin
aurait propulsé la France
dans un univers
de science-fiction.
Musique dramatique
...
-Pourquoi il y a eu une omerta
sur la présence
de scientifiques allemands
sur le territoire français ?
Je dirais que ça a été la même chose
aux Etats-Unis avec von Braun.
S'il est arrivé aux Etats-Unis,
c'était sous le plus grand secret.
Pendant quatre ou cinq ans,
personne n'était au courant,
surtout pas la presse.
Après, l'affaire a un peu explosé
avec le fait que von Braun
a été du parti nazi.
-Les recherches
conduites en Normandie
par les anciens collaborateurs
de Wernher von Braun
sont restées entourées jusqu'au bout
d'un épais mystère.
Eux-mêmes conservent
une discrétion totale
sur les raisons de leur présence.
-On savait qu'ils travaillaient
sur des moteurs de fusées,
sur des fusées,
mais à l'extérieur,
les pères ne parlaient de rien.
Souvent,
les épouses ne savaient pas
ce que faisait leur mari,
tellement c'était secret.
Ils ont été formés comme ça.
Tous les papiers
qui circulaient,
par exemple dans l'usine,
étaient tamponnés,
secrets et numérotés.
-Il y avait aussi
un petit côté cocorico
qui était
de ne pas trop révéler
que c'était grâce
aux cerveaux allemands
qu'on avait fabriqué
les premières fusées Véronique,
des fusées-sondes,
qui volaient à Hammaguir et autres.
La fierté nationale
était plutôt de montrer
que c'était grâce
aux ingénieurs français.
*-Ceci, c'est Véronique, la fusée.
-Les ingénieurs allemands de Vernon
se voient confier
le secteur propulsion des fusées.
-Le général de Gaulle
a demandé
à ce qu'on développe,
par exemple,
une fusée anti-avion,
la Parca,
qui a été développée au LRBA,
pour descendre
des bombardiers russes
qui sont chargés
de bombe atomique.
Ca, bien sûr,
en France,
on sait que c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait nouveau
et quelque chose
qui va faire changer le monde.
-Mais ces premiers missiles
sol-air ou mer-air,
impulsés par des équipes allemandes
rencontrent
des problèmes de guidage.
Le développement de plusieurs
fusées est abandonné.
Les ingénieurs allemands
se concentrent,
dans les années 60,
sur la conception
de moteurs de lancement
toujours plus puissants.
*-Ces réalisations spectaculaires
vont de Véronique,
dont il a déjà été tiré
plus de 70 exemplaires,
au premier étage Emeraude
du lance-satellite Diamant...
Le deuxième étage
du lanceur européen...
Ces deux derniers engins
réalisés...
-Les recrues allemandes
mettent au point
un moteur-fusée qui équipera
les premiers étages
de tous les lance-satellites
jusqu'en 2003, jusqu'au dernier vol
de la fusée Ariane 4.
-Ca a été comme ça que la France
a pu fabriquer des fusées
et devenir un peu leader
européen d'Ariane.
-Mission accomplie.
On estime que le travail
des scientifiques allemands
a fait gagner à la France
15 précieuses années
de recherches et d'études.
Ils sont, pour la plupart,
repartis.
L'Allemagne,
à partir des années 60,
a été en mesure de leur proposer
des postes équivalents.
Seules quelques familles
sont restées
en France,
sans attirer l'attention.
-Moi, ça ne m'a jamais troublé
qu'on soit restés
un peu dans l'ombre.
-Beaucoup ?
-Beaucoup dans l'ombre.
Non, ça nous a pas...
Je sais... Et mon père non plus.
Ca ne... Aucune...
D'aucune façon,
ça l'a troublé.
Musique dramatique
-Entourée par le secret-défense,
l'existence de ces colonies
allemandes sur le sol français
n'a jamais été portée
à la connaissance du grand public.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA